[Musique]
quand on pense à la perception du Canada
à l'étranger certains stéréotypes nous
viennent en tête là qui les Rocheuses la
politesse légendaire des Canadiens une
sorte d'Eden du vivre-ensemble et
d'autres clichés du genre mais dans la
foulée des années de pandémie sur le web
un peu partout dans le monde auprès de
certains cercles cette image a
subitement volé en éclat au profit d'un
portrait plus sombre du Canada fortement
inspiré par la pensée conspirationniste
Nicolas cette image classique du Canada
elle a été un peu écorchée dans certains
cercles surtout en lien au centre de
tout ça juste un Trudeau oui c'est ça
parce que Justin Trudeau bon ça fait
quand même des années que c'est plus
fervent des tracteurs disent que c'est
un communiste parce que bon bien sûr
c'est un chef d'État quand même de
gauche on a vu même des comparaisons on
disait que c'était un fils peut-être de
fidèle Castro on a beaucoup vu ça
circuler bien sûr sans fondement là
c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup
accentué avec la covid-19 avec les
manifestations contre les mesures
sanitaires qu'on a vu au Canada beaucoup
d'affiches beaucoup de publications en
ligne qui disait que Trudeau était un
dictateur qui était autoritaire avec les
mandats de vaccination avec des choses
comme les passeports vaccinaux qui
étaient là dans les provinces mais bon
quand même on associe ça à l'état et
c'est quelque chose qui s'est accentué
encore plus avec le convoi de la liberté
avec l'intervention bien sûr avec
l'invocation de la loi des mesures
d'urgence cette idée là que je suis
intrudo était un chef d'État autoritaire
c'est vraiment pris beaucoup
d'importance en 2022 ça c'est au Canada
Nicolas mais au-delà nos frontières
aussi on a eu on a vu ce genre de
discours de perception centrée sur
Justin Trudeau qui était qualifié par un
euro député de dictateur de la pire
espèce n'est plus ni moins là
trop technique
ça va surtout manger
de Justin Trudeau le dictateur ça se
rend jusqu'à là jusqu'au parlement
européen et bien l'expert de l'extrême
droite et chercheuse du centre
international en terrorisme Barbara
molasse dit qu'il y a une espèce de
transnationalisation de l'extrême droite
qui s'est créée au fil du temps avec
Internet
un espèce d'écosystème ou ce sont les
mêmes éléments des informations qui se
partagent notamment sur les vaccins on a
vu ma mission des critères en plus
souvent c'est souvent les mêmes
histoires qu'on voit un peu partout dans
le monde et avec ça avec les mêmes
termes les mêmes images les mêmes
éléments voilà et avec ça vient aussi
une image commune qui s'est créée
peut-être à travers tout ça de Justin
Trudeau comme un chef autoritaire et
bien sûr le convoi de la liberté comme
celui-ci grande couverture
internationale eu beaucoup d'impact avec
tout ça on reviendra sur l'extrême
droite transnationale Nicolas un peu
plus tard mais je comprends bien
l'écosystème comment tout ça c'est c'est
répandu à travers quel canon mais il
doit avoir un élément déclencheur à
travers tout ça en quelque part il y en
a plusieurs on peut nécessairement dire
que dans un seul mais chose certaine il
y a un peu de ça qui vient de notre
cours aussi je parlais avec Monsieur
Ahmed Al-Rawi qui est en charge du
dessin formations project de
l'université Fraser donc qui surveille
tout ce qui se passe avec les
informations en ligne et lui ce qu'il
dit c'est que au Canada on est un des
pays qui exporte le plus des
informations et qui contribue aussi à
cette nébuleuse de la droite de
l'extrême droite en ligne un exemple qui
l'a cité c'est le média alternatif
rebourne news un média assez campé à
droite qui a beaucoup couvert entre
autres le convoi des camionneurs il y a
beaucoup de leur journalistes qui sont
invités par exemple à afox news pour
commenter l'actualité et le fondateur de
robot news au fil des ans a beaucoup dit
que Justin Trudeau agissait comme un
dictateur de République de banane il
commençait à devenir un dictateur de se
qualifier de communiste de tyran donc je
veux pas reborn news on parle quand même
2,6 millions d'abonnés sur Youtube
Rainbow news qui a un grand public
international et quand leur tête
d'affiche tient des propos semblables ça
peut avoir une certaine influence
monsieur albraoui parle d'autres
Canadiens assez influents dans cette
nébuleuse de la droite en ligne comme
psychologue bien connu maintenant qui
participent même à qui même sa propre
émission au Déry wire un média
alternatif de droite aux États-Unis il
est dans croisade contre l'Ordre des
psychologues qui veut
qui veut lui faire suivre des formations
en ligne pour qu'il corrige son
comportement sur les réseaux sociaux
mais lui la manière qui parle de leur
dépucologues de manière qui parle de
l'État canadien c'est vraiment de l'État
autoritaire qui veut faire taire toute
dissidence et lui comme il a critiqué le
Premier ministre dit que c'est pour ça
que lors des psychologues l'attaque et
après ça bon on peut parler aussi
d'éléments aux États-Unis qui ont une
influence au sein de cette nébuleuse de
droite là on a mentionné c'est une autre
figure qui a couvert énormément ce qu'on
voit des camionneurs là objectif
qualificatif assez créatif et bon
d'autres personnes comme le podcasteur
et commentateurs de MMA lui aussi qui en
parlant du convoi a dit le Canada c'est
un pays communiste juste un Trudeau même
s'il paraît bien et tout ça c'est un
dictateur
encore une fois il y a des critiques
légitimes par rapport à ce qui se passe
au pays mais de là avoir ça comme une
espèce de dystopie autoritaire disons
que c'est plutôt discutable j'en ai
parlé avec Andrew romain qui dirige le
programme d'études canadienne à
l'université bridgewaters
Unis un peu comme ailleurs dans le monde
on parle très peu du Canada et quand on
va en parler aux États-Unis surtout dans
des sphères plus conservatrices c'est
pour utiliser le pays comme exemple de
ce que les États-Unis peuvent devenir si
on fait pas attention donc c'est
vraiment si on est comme un espèce
d'avertissement
[Musique]
sur la l'extrême droite transnationale
Nicolas on comprend ça sur le plan des
idées de l'idéologie de la rhétorique
mais sur le terrain concrètement est-ce
qu'il y a des exemples on le sait depuis
2019 au Pays-Bas il y a des
manifestations de fermiers parce que le
gouvernement veut mettre en place des
nouvelles normes environnementales qui
pourraient venir toucher leur production
bien sûr et encore une fois ce ne sont
pas des manifestations droite mais au
fil du temps il y a des éléments
d'extrême droite qui sont greffés à ces
manifestations là qui sont un peu
devenues espèces de manifestation
anti-système plus que des manifestations
contre ces nouvelles normes
environnementales là et pendant le
combat de la liberté au Canada il y
avait un élément de désinformation que
c'est beaucoup propagé en ligne de
tracteur qui bloquait des autoroutes au
Pays-Bas les manifestants Canadiens se
sont dit mon dieu c'est un geste de
solidarité avec nous et sont inspirés
par les camionnettes et on a commencé à
voir des drapeaux des Pays-Bas
apparaître aux manifestations au Canada
mais ces images de tracteurs-là
n'étaient pas nouvelles et n'étaient pas
inspiré du combat la liberté dater en
fait de 2019 mais il y a eu grâce à cet
élément des informations là et autres là
une espèce de solidarité qui s'est créée
entre deux mouvements donc on a vu des
drapeaux des Pays-Bas au Canada on a vu
des drapeaux du Canada au Pays-Bas et
c'était comme une cause commune qui
finalement était juste qui finalement
est une cause anti-système même si à la
base ces deux causes complètement
différente et bon ça ça montre en
quelque sorte à quel point que des bases
communicants entre ces mouvements anti
système là à travers tous les pays et
ouais qui l'eût cru voilà une autre
image de marque du Canada qu'on n'aurait
pas soupçonné à quelques années à peine